You have to work really hard if you don't want to get anywhere with whatever you do if you were called it off
You're gonna succeed. I just kind of laugh when I see people you know you know telling me
I've sold out or something like that cuz I haven't changed anything
I just feel so happy you know that I'm one of the few people
You know you can actually say that I you know I love what I'm doing
Leave motivation watch a top ten of the leaf nation
What's up?
at seven my one word is believe and I believe in you I believe you have an
Amazing gift inside you that I want to see explode out onto the world
So let's get your motivation to attend and get you believing in you grab a snack and chew on today's lessons from a man who?
Chose his stage name because his real name was already taken on MySpace
And then he went on to become one of the world's most popular and famous DJs
He's Avicii, and here's my take on his top ten rules of success enjoy
Alright let's kick things off with rule number one make it happen
My first got into making music. It came kind of together
Went on lonely the program first
That was the music I could make in the program before that I didn't really listen to much that I find music at all
There was all the house blogs I was always on on those websites
Just get the latest music to kind of
Get inspired really I in turn thought why not try to send my songs to each house box and see you know
If they can promote it or if they can you know Willie said?
My manager he messaged me on Facebook and
Just said that he you know came across my music and wanted to you know meet up. He's had a couple of ideas
That's what he kind of started getting real
I wanted to do music professionally like as a career rule number two is give it your all
try to figure out where you're
most passionate about in life and what you're good at and
the mixture between those two, and then you should give it your all all the time you shouldn't
You have to work really hard if you want to get and you work with whatever you do
If you work hard enough you're gonna succeed
And that's that's almost that's almost a fact I've seen it so many times rule number three
Just get started. How was the game changed with technology in music?
Well, I mean you don't really need anything anymore you need your computer
That's all you need you don't need any any keyboards
You don't need anything to produce interviews if you know the program like good quality music. You know and then obviously
You're gonna have to
You know you have to know melodies, and you know what not everyone can learn that, but it's definitely
Made it easier for so many people to get into this and you know get started with it
And and you know a lot of people maybe that before
Couldn't afford or didn't want to risk buying hardware for in you know thousands of dollars
Because they didn't know if they could produce or not
but now it's like all for pretty much nothing you can just download and
It's amazing things like GarageBand for example exactly yeah, or any of the pro. There's so many programs and
You know it's all about how you work with the program as well, so
No, it's it's just amazing. How how easy it is to get started now rule number four is find your path
I actually just downloaded my sequencer one night when I was at my parents
See like cottage in like my car. No. No I like I like on our summer summer vacation
Thing and I had nothing to do and I have trying to play the guitar and stuff like that for like two years
But I never got really good at it
And then I like read on on the internet about a program where you could paint your melodies. Oh my gosh
This is cool. So I kind of downloaded that and try doing like a remix of an old track called
lazy lazy Jones or canker for
400-some the nation
that ones I tried to remix of that one and
It ended up not really being a remix. Just just an original then I kind of got like stuck from that
Cuz it's so cold in Sweden for eight months out of 12
So there's not that much to do so you're kind of forced to to
define something to do and I think
DJing and production is like it's the perfect thing for people cannot escape from
the Swedish winter in a way and
Because everyone has this dream to be able to travel travel
The world you know and that can and since we've had so many people coming from Sweden who has been successful already
It doesn't feel that far-fetched
To be able to make it you know, I mean because people like Steve Angello
Sebastian Ingrosso acts well, but you know all these other house producers have already made it so it's so easy for people to
Like I could do that as well. You know what I mean
I think that's why there's so many people doing it in Sweden rule number five laugh at critics
What do you think of the tractors that attempt to claim your sound is too mainstream?
um I
Mean everyone has 30 as her own music tapes. I don't know
I haven't changed my sound a bit from when I started to know in order to
Please the mainstream. I've always been doing the music. I'm doing now
I always stay true to myself and you know like the music has become more popular
And you know the mainstream has open out
Instrumental tracks and stuff like that and I've always been interesting and doing these kind of like really melodic uplifting tracks
So I you know when I I just kind of laugh when I see people you know you know telling me
I've sold out or something like that because I haven't changed anything you know so I was wondering
Do you find it bothersome little when people say things like that?
Because as you said you've been creating the same sound for a very long time
So you haven't changed the only thing that has changed as more people have discovered you so does it feel weird to have people
essentially hating on your success
Yeah, I mean it's in the beginning it bothered me because you're like oh yeah
I want to tell this person that it's not like that
You know like are you?
You know kinda like are you stupid just look at you know mom you see then I look at my music now, but then
You know there. I used to notice the better things go like everyone said the more haters you get like by default
And I mean you can't say it to everyone and I mean it doesn't really matter
Anyway, so right now. I just felt like brush it off and don't really care that much but obviously it's
It's it's an annoying thing, but it's just something you have to overlook rule number six find your creative process
I'd say it's the number one most important thing every demo that we did
Started out as an acoustic version so like
We'd come up with a song from scratch, and then we do
Do it with just like a vocal and a piano and then?
I'd take those parts with me home
and then I'd make something of that when it comes to production and then this samples I use for my
Cakes, and then drums and stuff like that. I've kind of
Narrowed it down enough now. I've done and so much from from
My friends and you know
In the scene to we kind of share
like the best samples and stuff so I kind of have like a folder with you know these are the
Best songs that have you know all the night long
Rule number seven is find your inspiration
Like I could find the inspiration
From
Like if I hear if I hear we're really good house rock for instance
I can be like god this would be cool
But you could do it like this and say you know what I mean, so you get like inspiration
but then again you get inspiration from all types of musics really I mean you can get Alyssa to know right Ray Charles track and
Get really inspired by by like just a certain rhythm or whatever
You know and then try to make something out of that and try to make it into your own thing
Inside rule number eight is surround yourself with great people
I feel really fortunate that I've been surrounded by so many good people my manager and
That's been with me from the start, and I think that's it's really important
When Ash discovery first I didn't really know how to DJ
You know I was focusing on producing music and making music so I like I didn't even know how I was gonna
format if I was gonna perform in any way for me to
Perform it when I met her she just took it to a whole nother level
Like professional like when I'm and he really took me out of nowhere, and then really built my career
And I couldn't I wouldn't be here without that rule number nine my personal favorite is love. What you do I
Just feel so happy you know that I'm one of the few people
Who you know can actually say that I you know?
I love what I'm doing and I've gotten to the point where I'm at today you know
It's I it's amazing like I still can't believe it
So you've essentially made it what's next on the agenda for Avicii
Just keep I mean keep doing and keep building it for for as long as I can and for for as long as I'm still
As long as I'm still loving it you know
which is
Essentially what's been so the most important thing for me since day one
And rule number ten the last one before the bonus is have fun blondes or brunettes
wall
Do you like to sing just in the shower anything I sing yeah - my to myself no one hears ya I
Probably, I really like actually I like being in the studio when no one hears me, and I guess a good stuff. Yeah
Every time I write stuff I try to but I
Can't do it in front of anyone because I feel like I get super nervous and super shy straight away
I'll sing it right. Do you want to sing something right now? Yeah absolutely not oh?
Yeah, you're not gonna get me with that. No way no way that's wasn't it in for me to try to do this
All right, I got some special Avicii bonus clips for you
But before getting to that my question of the day is around rule number nine love what you do
I want to know what is the thing that you love to do most in your business?
What is the thing that gets you super pumped up and alive leave it down the comments below?
I'm looking forward to hearing from you. Thank you guys so much for watching
I believe in you. I hope you continue to believe in yourself, and whatever you're one where it is much love
I'll see you soon, and enjoy the bonus clips
I started out with what FL Studio. I started leaking stuff on blogs basically because
it was easier, and it was easy to get the
Just how do you say when you're the
The
Tension because it's hard to get labels when you're unknown you know so I can start leaking stuff
And I got found by my manager. I used to mail the owners of the blog and
And just I mean like here. Here's my music. You know do you like it and you do you want to?
Would you it would be okay to put it on the blog and stuff like that and then they basically because for every
blogger it seems like
They love the promotion aspect of it because they don't want just the music either they want to like feel like they were doing something
I mean good, so they say so they gave a lot of feedback. I like how this real kid look
This is my space
You know look at these tracks and stuff like that so next up is the DJ had my tea this evening
I'm a huge fan
He's amazing
Get ready for a beachy
Raise your standard Apple at the core its core value is that?
that people need passion and
Not one drop of myself work depends on Europe, it's something to me. I don't ever give up. I'd have to be dead
Or completely incapacitated hey believe nation if you want to see my all-time
Favorite top ten most of success. I have a very special secret video for you
These are the individual clips that I have personally learned the most from and applied to my life and my business
Check the link in description for details